it's the biggest toy fair in the Western
Hemisphere where toy makers show off
their latest
games
gadgets and fun stuff to potential
commercial buyers we're meeting
today any toy imaginable you can find it
here and if you think this is only for
kids think again we're seeing a few
Trends um one of them is cadal which is
essentially parents buying more toys not
just for their kids but also for the
grown-ups and their family so games are
great it's a great example there's a lot
of games here that are great for the
family but there's also games that are
geared more towards the adult crowd
Collectibles are another great example
and then there's your Classic Toys the
ones that I played with when I was a kid
or my mom played with when she was a kid
and now it has come back in a new
iteration or just coming back in its
classic form this year there are toy
makers here from over over 80 countries
the toy industry likes to say that toys
are the language of
Joy toys are all about fun and games for
sure but they are also about very big
international
business the global toy Market reached
over
$17 billion last year alone and a big
reason is China which accounts for about
75% of the global toy market and 90% of
the world's toy factories the United
States however Imports more than $33
billion worth of toys every year more
than any other country and when it comes
to the largest toy companies look to
Europe Lego the Danish maker of the
popular plastic construction toys holds
the title as the largest toy company in
the world in sales last year raking in
about $9 billion in total
revenue a big industry indeed that
starts here this week with Buyers
getting a first look at the newest toys
from around the world Gabriel oando Al
jazer New
York make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer